[Music]
I'm really excited about this outfit
Adam felt this cute in a really long
time I'm kidding no but I am sorry about
this habit okay so basically my mom and
I went to Topshop yesterday and we got
this shirt and got this little bralette
skirt Topshop I forgot where the shoes
are from this is from Zara I forgot
where these earrings are from Punk
Christmas et caught up with Camilla
Kibeho at z100 Jingle Ball in New York
on Friday night the 20 year old singer
revealed some tidbits about her upcoming
solo album is set for release next month
yeah so my album is available for
pre-order right now and when you if you
pre-order it you get havana and you also
get two new songs which are I love them
they're like my babies never be the same
and real friends and so real friends is
that - the last song that I wrote for
the album and never be the same and
Havana was the first so it's cool that
it's like kind of the journey and yeah
so you I'm really really excited but for
these next few weeks
Camila plans to spend the holidays
laying low and listening to her favorite
holiday song I'm just gonna chill
definitely gonna chill for a little bit
yeah go to holiday song I love Justin
Bieber's Christmas album like mistletoes
Christmas song it's good album